Let's go.
Uh, let's go.
Where do we want to go next?
Let's try the five one, two area code.
Who's calling today from five one two.
Yo, what's up, baby?
Sorry.
This is who you're breaking up.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Is Freddie Mac?
I'm going to bad area on Friday.
I've got kind of a two part question, if that's
okay.
Sure.
All right.
I'll call it into the Jesse Peterson show.
And I know you did the show.
I watched it.
Um, and when I started proving him wrong,
because he was naming democratic policies,
he didn't know was put in place by progressive.
I told him, Hey, well, it seems like you'd
like progressive motor and you're like Republicans.
He started screaming Beta male and all this
other stuff.
My question to you is with guys like you and
Sam Cedar, it seemed like they're scared of,
why don't you guys push the issue to big them?
Because you're already right.
Well listen, I mean, Jesse Lee Peterson invited
me onto his program last time I was in la
and I did it.
So I mean, I dunno.
It's like, I think I'm doing it.
I don't know how frequently I should be debating
Jesse Lee Peterson.
He's got a relatively small audience and like,
I dunno how it's going to be the same thing
again, but I'm, I'm not against it.
And I have debated him, I guess you could
call it [inaudible].
Well, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Maybe I wasn't clear enough.
And not just him in particular, but I'm talking
about people like Candace.
Oh,
oh, Dave Rubin.
Yeah.
I mean, the two people you just named won't
debate me, so I don't know Candace Owens.
So we were supposed to, we were both offered
money by a third party to do a debate.
The third party said, she's good to go.
I said, great, let's pick topics on a date.
And at that point they said, oh, you know,
it's taking a little longer.
It's taking a little longer.
And then eventually, yeah, she's not going
to do it.
And then Dave Ruben, I've said, any time I
would have him back on this show or appear
on his and just nothing's happening yet, I
don't think he's interested.
Oh, okay.
One more question about our reparations.
Okay.
At first I was a guest reparations and I'm
black.
Okay.
And when I found out I did research, I found
out the sleazy, both those were paid reparations.
Sorry.
You figure, figured out who was, you broke
up, who was paid reparations?
The slave owners.
When slavery was, was abolished, you mean?
Yeah,
yes.
Yeah, I don't know too much about that.
Well, what I'm saying is people try to tell
me, well, if you didn't go through slavery,
you shouldn't get the money for it.
And I see go from my uncle died in the accident
and his sons got the money from blogs and
they got the [inaudible] Brett, you're breaking
up.
I don't know enough about that to be able
to say more than I've already said.
Your, your connection is just getting crazy,
but your first part was brilliant and I really
appreciate you calling in.
Yeah.
All right.
Thank you, David.
Okay, Freddy, great to hear from you.